it's not often that I can come to you
the david pakman show audience and say
hey Donald Trump accomplished something
Donald Trump set some kind of record
Donald Trump has done something historic
that we can talk about but I can do that
today Donald Trump has finally
accomplished something historic in his
presidential campaign he has managed to
rack up zero major newspaper
endorsements this is a first for any
major party nominee in American history
now I'm not overstating the importance
of newspaper endorsements newspaper
endorsements they probably don't really
change too many voters minds uh but it
still does tell us something when not a
single major newspaper has endorsed
Donald Trump Jack Pitney is a professor
of government at California's Claremont
McKenna College he said to the rap quote
it's significant the cumulative effect
of all these defections could have an
impact on moderate Republicans now let's
give you some context in 2012 16 of what
are considered the major newspaper
endorsements went to MIT Romney the
Republican nominee 16 major newspapers
didn't endorse anybody and 28 major
newspapers endorsed then sitting
president barack obama and we've covered
the decisions made by individually
traditionally conservative newspapers as
well and there are conservative papers
that have endorsed Republicans for
decades decades 40 years in many cases I
think some of them even something like
60 years and they have broken with
tradition and instead have endorsed
Hillary Clinton or at the very least
have said we're not endorsing Hillary
but don't vote for Trump so for example
you've got the Dallas Morning News which
endorsed every single Republican nominee
since nineteen forty we're talking about
76 years here they were so appalled by
the idea of President Donald Trump that
they introduced a Clinton endorsement
with the caveat we don't come to this
decision easily this newspaper has not
recommended a Democrat for the nation's
highest office since before World War
two if you're counting that's more than
75 years in nearly two
elections you've got the cincinnati
enquirer editorial board which broke
from a nearly hundred year long
tradition of backing Republicans to
support Hillary Clinton telling its
readers quote this is not a traditional
race and these are not traditional times
and then you have the Arizona Republic
which also endorsed Hillary Clinton the
last time that the Arizona Republic this
this is so insane it sounds almost
unbelievable 1890 was the last time Pat
that the Arizona Republic endorsed
someone other than a Republican in
you've made your point but add one more
to that list USA Today which usually
stays out of this kind of thing yeah uh
they haven't endorsed the president 34
years they didn't choose to endorse
Hillary but they basically said don't
vote for Trump yeah USA Today not
traditionally a paper a publication that
endorses at all so this is really not
good for Trump now here's the thing
let's let's view this okay if you are a
non Trump supporter you would see this
and you would say that will definitely
convince everyone not to vote for Donald
Trump right but if you are a trump
supporter you would see this and you
would say no newspapers are endorsing
Donald Trump all the more reason to vote
for him it means that the liberal media
is scared that's the rationale that a
lot of Trump supporters will put into
play and even with the sexual assault
allegations which are just flowing
freely like a waterfall Niagara Falls
they say these are trumped up charges
Bill Clinton's much worse this is all
just meant to hurt Trump and my support
of him has been renewed now and there
are many conservative papers to uh
Rupert Murdoch runs quite a few
including the wall street journal right
and even they aren't endorsing Trump
yeah it's it's historic in terms of what
it represents I don't care I've said
many times I don't know that
endorsements do much at all I think
taken in total if you said all of the
endorsements in total for a candidate
they probably do something do they move
the needle you know at this point in our
electoral vote system we're talking
about a few voters in a few states that
are ultimately going to decide whether
Trump ekes out a win whether Hillary
wins by a modest margin or
Hillary Clinton wins by a historic
margin and I don't know to what extent
these these endorsements matter Trump
also i will note has no endorsements or
votes from any living president right
people who have done the job before that
are alive none of them have endorsed
Donald Trump nor do they plan to vote
for Donald Trump as near as we can tell
and we had news about George HW Bush and
George W Bush initially they were
staying out and then reports that at
least George HW Bush is going to be
voting for Hillary Clinton I'm not
totally sure whether that's been proven
or not kinda doesn't matter Pat because
the big picture messages there are
former Republican presidents who don't
want to be anywhere near Trump or any of
this campaign missing from the from the
convention missing from endorsements
they don't want anything to do with him
yeah the question now is who is
supporting him among you know people in
Congress yet like Al Ahly like elected
officials is very few and what's funny
is I think I don't even know if I got
well I did tell you this yet after the
Trump audio leaked over the over last
weekend a bunch of Republicans
unendorsed Trump and some of them have
stuck with it right John McCain said I'm
not voting for Trump that's it period of
Jon Huntsman and Mitt Romney so many
people a lot of people backing away from
Trump altogether there are a few whose
names I won't even mention because
they're clearly such political
opportunists that they don't even
deserve me mentioning them on the show
they had originally endorsed Trump the
[ __ ] gate audio leaked and they said oh
I'm no longer endorsing Trump and or not
voting for him but then they came back
to trump after the second debate what's
more weaselly than that pad I mean it is
your view on Trump changing so
drastically that every few days you have
to make a public pronouncement these are
just people calculating am I better off
being on the list of Trump friends or
foes as as of how the wind is blowing
this morning it's pathetic yeah you've
gotta make your position and stick to it
yet through High Times and low times
you're gonna get a lot more respect from
the public out of that I would respect
going down with the ship the nun
endorsing and then endorsing explaining
why you initially endorsed and
explaining why you won endorsed and now
why you've rien doors just commit to
going down with the ship if it goes down
or sailing to victory if that's what
Alton
ly happens I've talked about how people
of all ages but particularly Millennials
are owning cars less and participating
more in the sharing economy and one of
the more popular options is zip car
which gets you a car when you want it
when you need it they offer all sorts of
cars SUVs hybrids whatever you need it
includes insurance and it includes gas
you just pay for the time that you
actually use the car and you can reserve
the car online from your smartphone over
the phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1,600 pounds per year for our
audience zipcar is offering $25 a free
driving credit if you sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com / David support our show
reduce your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at join zipcar
dot-com / David